What do we knlow about X-Force?
We will be known as X-Force."
"Isn't that a little derivative?"
Well, besides that.
We know Drew Goddard is writing and directing,
and he plans to focus on Deadpool, Cable,
and Domino.
There was already plenty of stuff up in the
air before the Disney-Fox merger, but now
things are even more muddled.
But there's no reason to lose hope just yet.
No matter what Disney plans to do with our
favorite merc-with-a-mouth, all signs point
toward Goddard, Ryan Reynolds, and the rest
giving us at least one great movie featuring
X-Force.
Here's a look at all the X-Force rumors and
spoilers that have leaked so far.
Rated R
If there's one consensus about X-Force, it's
that just about everyone wants it to be rated
R. Ryan Reynolds told Collider he thinks that'll
be the case, but it's too soon to say with
certainty, telling them,
"My sort of wild guess would be that it would
be an R-rated movie, but again, right now
we're just assembling the troops to figure
out what story we would tell."
Even the writers not working on X-Force are
sure we'll get an R rating.
Deadpool 2 writer Rhett Reese told CBR that
X-Force will almost definitely be rated R.
You might wanna look away from this.
Now this little piggy went to..."
Back from the dead
One of Deadpool 2's most hilariously unexpected
scenes gave us the very messy deaths of most
of the original X-Force's lineup.
Although, by the end of the film, one lucky
member did get resurrected from Deadpool's
post-credits time-hopping.
But even though Deadpool brought Peter back
from the dead, it's unclear if the rest of
X-Force was so lucky.
But Phillip Tan, who played Shatterstar in
Deadpool 2, says he will absolutely be returning
for X-Force.
Speaking to Syfy, Tan predicted,
"You're going to see more of my character
in the X-Force film."
Tan added that he's received a lot great fan
reaction from his death in Deadpool 2, and
he hopes the rest of the original doomed lineup
will be returning too.
Shatterstar might have a loophole not available
to the rest of the others: Deadpool 2 stayed
at least partly faithful to the character's
origin in the comics.
"So where are you from?"
"Planet Mojoworld?"
"So, you're an alien?
How does that help us?"
That alien origin could help by bringing Shatterstar
back for X-Force.
Mister Sinister
Movieweb thinks there's a good chance the
X-Force movie may introduce us to Mister Sinister,
whose introduction was originally planned
for Logan before director James Mangold decided
to cut him.
In the comics, Mister Sinister's birth name
is Nathaniel Essex, and that name has been
popping up throughout the X movies.
In X-Men: Apocalypse, men from something called
"Essex Corp" were shown collecting Logan's
blood.
Essex is also the name of the school that
tortured Russell and other mutant students
in Deadpool 2.
It's also worth noting that the headmaster
of the Essex School is never given a proper
name, referred to in the credits only as "The
Headmaster."
It could be that "The Headmaster" has a comeback
in store, despite his fatal ending in Deadpool
2.
"The day of reckoning is here!"
If he were secretly Mister Sinister, that
would hardly matter.
The villain has survived far worse.
Free-spirited Deadpool
The Deadpool movies featured Wade Wilson in
a long-term relationship with Vanessa, but
in the comics, his sexuality goes far beyond
heterosexual.
Longtime Deadpool comic book writer Gerry
Duggan says the Merc with a Mouth is, quote,
"ready and willing to do anything with a pulse."
He's flirted with heroes like Thor and Spider-Man
in the comics, and we saw a little bit of
this with Wade's fixation on Colossus in Deadpool
2.
Ryan Reynolds has been clear that he wants
to explore Deadpool's pansexuality.
At the 2018 San Diego Comic-Con, he said one
of the reasons he loves working on Deadpool
is that they can break the usual superhero
boundaries, adding that LGBTQ representation
is something he wants represented more in
superhero movies, specifically through Wade.
Since all the unanswered questions posed by
the Disney-Fox merger mean that X-Force could
very well be Reynolds' last crack at the character,
it may be do-or-die time for Deadpool to demonstrate
his romantic fluidity on screen.
A post-merger prognosis
It's a strange time to be a part of a Marvel
franchise in Fox's stable, and with the Disney-Fox
merger official, fans are wondering about
the future of all things X.
If Disney proves unwilling to be the home
of R-rated superhero movies, then that would
likely mean the end of the Deadpool movie
franchise, and subsequently, that X-Force
would be a waste of time and resources.
We'll just have to wait and see if Deadpool
can survive an MCU merger in all his foul-mouthed,
violent glory.
"Oh, it's so hard to go.
I just love being around you guys so much.
So, so much."